er ist der mächtigste und reichste mann
thailands könig maha vajiralongkorn oder
kurz rama der zehnte sohn des legendären
und überaus beliebten vaters und königs
bhumibol seit 2016 herrscher über das
königreich thailand sohn rama ist beim
volk allerdings unbeliebt lebt
vorzugsweise in einem luxushotel in
garmisch partenkirchen und führt auch
sonst einen eher unkonventionellen
lebensstil in thailand regt sich schon
länger widerstand gegen den könig die
pro demokratie bewegung will rama den
zehnten vom thron stoßen die bei den
thais beliebte könig schwester siering
dorn die den konflikt mit ihrem
extrovertierten bruder nicht scheut
musste ins krankenhaus nachdem sie sich
bei einem spaziergang mit ihrem bruder
beide knöchel gebrochen hatte jetzt der
nächste skandal der die thailänder
fassungslos macht der verheiratete rama
will offenbar seine zweitfrau auch zur
königin krönen lassen als kleines
geschenk zum 36
geburtstag und obwohl bigamie also das
mehrfach verheiratet sein in thailand
wie auch in deutschland offiziell
verboten und strafbar ist doch für rama
den zehnten gottähnliche könig thailands
gelten offenbar schon länger keine
weltlichen gesetze mehr ja- und all die
exklusiven details dieser geschichte die
besprechen wir jetzt mit max böddeker
unser experte für das thailändische
königshaus hallo max wie kann das sein
dass man einfach so ein geschenk machen
kann es vergeht einem jahr auf der zunge
weil wir auch gerne alle haben solche
positionen zum geburtstag aber wie kann
das sein
wie kann das sein dass du so was machen
kommen weil das kann ganz einfach wenn
der thailändische könig ist weil das
eben in der anmoderation gehört haben
eben gott gleich ist eigentlich darf es
nicht weil die bigamie ist einfach
verboten in thailand seit 1935 aber
erschwert sich eben nicht um mehr macht
das ganz einfach
jetzt lasst uns mal weiter über das
liebesleben des königs sprechen denn das
geht ja also könnte man sagen auf und ab
wir schreiben uns einmal die
protagonisten also wir brauchen die
königin wir brauchen die geliebte und
wir brauchen die beziehung zwischen den
beteiligten personen gut also ich
versuche mir ganz klar zu machen
deswegen zum einen könig machen
war ihre long kann der ein bisschen
extrovertiert drücken wir es mal so es
ist ja ganz einfach und dann haben wir
königin zu tiger die am 19 mai 2009 10
gehe licht hat gleichzeitig hatte er
aber damals schon seine geliebte koi
also die war früher krankenschwester und
was in seinem harem dann ist sie
befördert worden so generalmajor in also
ganz ganz schnell dann zur zweitfrau und
die wird eben jetzt dann wenn für könig
alles gut geht die zwei königin auch und
wir haben aber noch eine weitere person
das ist prinzessin sirion korn
das ist die schwester des königs und ich
bin ganz ganz bedeutende rolle dabei die
ist nämlich gegen diese beziehung
beziehungsweise gegen diese beförderung
vom co und koi und der könig haben sich
ja auch ein paar nachrichten geschrieben
die du uns auch exklusiv mitgebracht
hast ja was genau ist dort in diesen
nachrichten ausgetauscht worden
ausgeschafft worden sind einfach reine
ja liebeserklärungen sagen wir mal so in
zahlen form also sie hat zum beispiel
ein foto wir sehen es auch gerade
gemacht beziehungsweise collage da steht
halt 904 904 ist der der deckname des
königs wenn irgendwo öffentlich
unterwegs ist und bei ihr zum beispiel 0
11 0 11 ist der ja die position im harem
des königs er hat sie alle
durchnummeriert damit dass ich da noch
nicht alle namen merken müssen muss als
keine ahnung
und das hat sie ihm also geschickt und
einiges mehr
und jetzt beschreiben uns einmal was
bedeutet das denn für das thailändische
volk werden das jetzt besprochen als sei
es eine seifenoper sich das eingangs ja
auch gesagt aber letztendlich was
bedeutet der könig und auch seine
entscheidungen die er jetzt trifft für
das thailändische volk das thailändische
volk ist natürlich nicht besonders
amüsiert mit der ganzen geschichte
ich habe im prinzessin sirindhorn schon
erwähnt wird im land auch app genannt
das heißt so viel wie eine prinzessin
ist im land sehr sehr beliebt
und er soll sich auch vergangene woche
soll eine auseinandersetzung mit ihr
gehabt haben und im zuge dieser
auseinandersetzung sollte sich schwer
verletzt haben nach außen wurde so
dargestellt dass sie beim spazierengehen
mit beiden beinen gleichzeitig
umgeknickt um geknackt ist weiß nicht du
als frau kannst du vielleicht die
wahrscheinlichkeit besser einschätzen
kann haben passieren könnte auch mit
einem passieren irgendwo erholen hatten
aber in wirklichkeit war so er hatte die
auseinandersetzung mit ihr und ist ja
sagen wir mal so scheinbar an gebäude
gegangen die wurde daneben operiert und
ist jetzt im rollstuhl und wird
monatelang nicht laufen können
das spricht sich natürlich im
thailändischen bevölkerung rum und führt
dazu dass jetzt eben diese anti
monarchie bewegung wieder auflodert und
aufflammt und das könnte dann im zweifel
soll für den könig in ganz ganz böses
oder bitteres ende
also zumal er sich ja auch über
geltendes teilen das ist recht einfach
hinweg setzt er ist eben der omnipotente
wonach der tut und macht was er will und
das bevor die anti monarchie bewegungen
thailand kann er das denn so einfach
sich über dieses recht hinwegsetzen oder
befürchte dass du dass das jetzt in den
kommenden tagen irgendwie in irgendeiner
form konsequenzen haben könnte kommt es
auf alle fälle machen wie gesagt er hat
ja kein regularium um sich herum also ja
er macht einfach weil es kann aber es
könnte ja auch konsequenzen haben wenn
er wieder nach deutschland zurück
für mich vergessen ist jetzt so lange
zeit in thailand das war aber noch nie
so lange in thailand und er will
irgendwann wieder nach deutschland
zurück und auch nach deutschem recht ist
die bgi verboten wenn er zurückkommt
muss auch deutsches recht halten und er
kann sich nicht darauf berufen er hat es
sind diplomatenpass er reist ja laut
thailändischer auffassung eben als
privatperson und das könnte auch für ihn
probleme in deutschland an geben jetzt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren